tomémonos en un plano cartesiano una
línea recta como esta que sea horizontal
y como es una línea recta horizontal
entonces es la forma que igual a una
constante así que déjenme ponerlo por
acá a esta recta le voy a llamar que es
igual a una constante porque es una
línea horizontal eso ya lo sabemos y
además me voy a tomar un punto pero este
punto no va a estar en mi línea recta me
voy a tomar un punto fuera de mi línea
recta y voy a suponer que es este de
aquí y este punto tiene como coordenadas
a b y bueno este punto de aquí le voy a
llamar el foco porque vamos a hablar
acerca de unos puntos que cumplan una
propiedad bastante interesante y bueno
de hecho yo lo que me quiero fijar es en
esta propiedad que te voy a decir lo que
voy a buscar son todos los puntos que
existen o que tengan la misma distancia
de este punto a esta recta que por
cierto a esta recta le voy a poner el
nombre de directriz directriz y esta
palabra nunca le había oído sin contar
el contexto de una parábola que es y ya
viste el título del vídeo pues sabrás
que éste
y habla acerca de parábolas y bueno a
este punto de aquí le voy a llamar el
foco este va a ser mi foco me voy a
fijar en todos los puntos que existan de
este punto y de esta directriz es decir
aquellos puntos que la distancia del
punto al foco y la distancia del punto a
la directriz sea la misma
y bueno claramente el primero tú me vas
a enseñar es este de aquí el punto medio
entre mi foco y mi directriz que es este
de aquí sin embargo si te das cuenta
aquí tenemos a otro este de aquí también
cumple que equidista tanto del foco como
de la directriz y ojo me estoy tomando
recuerda la distancia más pequeña porque
me podría fijar tal vez en esta
distancia pero entonces tendría un grave
problema porque esta instancia es mucho
más grande que la distancia de este
punto al foco por lo tanto recuerda que
cuando hablo de distancia de un punto a
una recta me refiero a la distancia más
pequeña es decir a esta distancia y
bueno aquí ya tengo varios y como ya
viste el título del vídeo pues la
gráfica que hay de estos puntos es una
parábola que se va a ver
o menos así estoy tratando de dibujar a
mi parábola y esta parábola cumple que
cualquier punto de ella está a la misma
distancia del foco que de la directriz
es más podemos dibujar a otro por aquí
fíjate si yo me tomo a este de aquí este
punto déjame cambiar de color
su distancia al foco de esta parábola
pues es exactamente la misma que la
distancia a la directriz y bueno de
hecho lo que quiero ver en este vídeo no
es el dibujo de una parábola sino
matemáticamente hablando descubrir que
los puntos que cumplen que la distancia
del foco a este punto es exactamente la
misma que la distancia de la recta a
este punto tienen como ecuación la
ecuación de una parábola es justo lo que
quiero ver en este vídeo así que vamos a
tomarnos algún punto que cumpla con esta
propiedad este punto de aquí que le voy
a poner que tiene coordenadas x james y
x ye para hacer las diferentes del foco
este punto de aquí voy a decir que
cumplen que la distancia de este punto
al foco es exactamente la misma que de
este punto
pero vamos a fijarnos en la distancia de
este punto al foco que le voy a llamar
de 1 cual es la distancia de un punto a
otro pues es x menos han elevado al
cuadrado
la diferencia de los valores de x más o
menos ven elevado al cuadrado la
diferencia en las coordenadas de james
ya esto les acabamos raíz cuadrada ésta
es la distancia de un punto a otro y que
por cierto es mi distancia de 1 pero
bueno recuerda que este punto cumple una
propiedad muy importante cumple la
propiedad de que la distancia del punto
al foco es exactamente la misma así lo
estamos construyendo que es la distancia
de este punto a la directriz es decir
esta distancia de quique le voy a llamar
de 2 y quedas la distancia de 2 bueno si
te das cuenta lo único que estoy
haciendo para moverme de la directriz a
este punto es moverme en la coordenada
en x es exactamente lo mismo por lo
tanto puedo decir que esto es lo mismo
que yo - acá porque mi directriz tiene
como ecuación asociada igual acá
entonces es
y menos acá porque no me muevo en x pero
no puedo asegurar forzosamente que esto
sea positivo para hacerlo positivo
siempre puede hacer que sea una parábola
que esté arriba o abajo de la directriz
y entonces para hacerlo positivo siempre
lo que voy a hacer es una trampa me voy
a tomar esto elevado al cuadrado que es
positivo y le voy a sacar la raíz
cuadrada de tal manera que ya con esto
puedo asegurar que esta distancia
siempre es positiva y además que se
cumple esta igualdad por construcción
precisamente porque tenemos este punto
que es nuestro punto importante y bueno
ya que tengo estos dos ahora sí vamos a
ver si logramos encontrar la ecuación de
una parábola desde aquí que por cierto
hasta ahorita no parece la ecuación de
una parábola pero vamos a ver aquí
llegamos lo primero que voy a hacer es
elevar al cuadrado a ambos lados de la
ecuación y que me queda bueno pues la
raíz se va con el cuadrado y me queda x
menos a elevado al cuadrado más o menos
b elevado al cuadrado y del otro lado
pues la raíz y el cuadrado se van y
siempre sencillamente me queda que menos
k elevado al cuadrado lo que estoy
haciendo es elevar al cuadrado ambos
lados de la ecuación y bueno el
siguiente paso que voy a hacer
voy a expandir estoy menos elevado al
cuadrado y está menos k elevado al
cuadrado así que vamos a dejar esto
igualito x menos a elevado al cuadrado y
este segundo binomio cuadrado perfecto
lo voy a expandir me va a quedar
cuadrada menos dos veces lleve más be
cuadrada y de igual manera del lado
derecho de la ecuación me queda ya
cuadrada menos dos veces el primero por
el segundo menos dos llega más acá
cuadrada
es decir estoy expandiendo los dos
mínimos del cuadrado perfecto que tienen
que ver con james porque está ya
cuadrada y estaría cuadrada son iguales
y como están de lados distintos de la
ecuación
entonces se cancelan si yo restó ya
cuatro haremos la ecuación se cancelan y
entonces que me quedan y fíjate que ya
se van pareciendo un poco más el
ecuación de una parábola porque ya tengo
algo de la forma y es igual a algo de x
elevado al cuadrado pero bueno vamos a
escribirlo de nuevo para ver qué es lo
que nos está quedando me quedan x menos
a elevado al cuadrado
- dos veces lleve más be cuadrada
recuerda que ya cancelamos las 10
cuadradas es igual a menos dos veces ya
k más cara cuadrada y ya se parece un
poquito más a una parábola a
continuación lo que voy a hacer es pasar
todo esto que tengo aquí del otro lado
de la ecuación para que de este lado del
lado izquierdo me queda solamente x
menos a elevado al cuadrado x menos a
elevado al cuadrado es igual a quién y
bueno voy a pasar todo esto del lado
derecho entonces va a pasar con signo
contrario si yo sumo dos veces lleve de
ambos lados de la ecuación me queda dos
veces lleven del lado derecho y del lado
izquierdo se cancelan y después me queda
menos dos veces llegan y después voy a
pasar estévez cuadrada del otro lado de
la ecuación con signo contrario y va a
pasar como menos b cuadrada menos b
cuadrada y después a esto hay que
agregarle más cara cuadrada que es
estaca cuadrada que tenemos aquí
perfecto y darte cuenta como poco a poco
cada vez esto se parece más a la
ecuación de una parábola es decir a algo
que tiene que ver con x elevado al
cuadrado x
o sea elevado al cuadrado y del otro
lado aquí tenemos al menos una constante
y pues de hecho vamos a recordar mejor
como se veía la ecuación de una parábola
así que déjenme agarrar el color
amarillo y recordemos un poco cómo se va
a ver la ecuación una parábola o a que
queremos llegar una parábola se veía más
o menos así x menos a elevado al
cuadrado del mismo que menos ve bueno
aquí les efecto una constante que la voy
a poner aquí una a mayúscula y no no no
no me a mayúscula no se ve nada así que
mejor déjame escribirlo aquí a por x
menos y para que la amigos claro se
confunda con la mayúscula déjame tomar
otra letra le voy a poner la letra a b x
menos b elevado al cuadrado espero que
no te confunda esto al final es x menos
una constante eleva al cuadrado y esto
multiplicado por otra constante llamada
esto es igual a ye menos ven a esto más
o menos queremos llegar y ésta es justo
mi ecuación de una parábola así que ya
casi vamos por ahí fíjate que ya va
apareciendo se cada vez un poco más a
esto lo que estamos llegar es que el
lado derecho de la ecuación tenga la
forma menos
así que lo primero que voy a hacer de
este cuestión que tengo aquí es
factorizar allí
del lado derecho voy a factorizar allí y
que me va a quedar bueno déjame
escribirlo aquí abajo si tengo
suficiente espacio creo que sí hacer
entonces tomemos otro color y del lado
izquierdo nos sigue quedando x menos an
así que déjame ponerlo aquí estos x
menos ha elevado al cuadrado x menos han
elevado al cuadrado es igual y del lado
derecho voy a factorizar la jem y me
queda ya que multiplica quien bueno
multiplica a 2 b -2 k2b menos 2 camps
que a su vez multiplican a james y
después de lo que me sobra voy a
factorizar aquí un signo menos para que
se vaya apareciendo cada vez más hay
menos b por lo tanto voy a actualizar un
menos y menos quien bueno menos y voy a
poner menos paréntesis b cuadrado menos
k cuadrada lo que quiero hacer es que
los signos me sigan concordando y
realmente van bien menos por más menos
menos por menos más menos b cuadrada más
a cuadrada ahí está perfecto y entonces
ahora lo que voy a hacer es ahora
factorizar un 2 entonces lo que voy a
hacer es escribir lo mismo y factorizar
primero un 2 del lado derecho y me queda
x menos ha elevado al cuadrado es igual
a 2 que multiplica a b - k que a su vez
multiplica james menos y esta de aquí
este de aquí es una diferencia de
cuadrados si tú te acuerdas de tus
clases factorización me vas a decir que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que vemos
acá por b menos camps éste de que es una
diferencia de cuadrados y ponerlo así me
va a servir para simplificar un poco las
cosas de mascar por b menos acá y bueno
ahora ya que tengo todo esto lo que voy
a hacer es o es que fíjate en esta
ecuación que tengo aquí abajo de
amarillo tengo a la insólita por lo
tanto lo que me estorba todavía es el 2
que multiplica el de menos acá y para
quitarlo pues lo que voy a hacer es
dividir todo entre todos que multiplica
a de menos acá o entre 1 entre 2 por b -
cambio es lo mismo entonces que me va a
quedar y bueno como ya no tengo
suficiente espacios lo voy a poner aquí
1 entre 2 que multiplica avn - acá voy a
multiplicar todos
y bueno del lado izquierdo me va a
quedar x menos elevado al cuadrado que
multiplica a esta constante y del lado
derecho me va a quedar este 2 volver
menos acá es justo lo que se va a
cancelar con este 1 entre 2 x b menos
camps y después le queda 1 / 2 por ver
menos acá por demás que vuelve menos que
esto se cancelan este y este de aquí
abajo se cancelan y siempre
sencillamente me queda de más acá entre
2 el b menos acá se va a cancelar y
bueno ya que tengo
justo lo que tenía que arriba fíjate en
este caso la a va a representar 1 entre
2 por ver menos acá es una constante que
está multiplicando a algo que es de la
forma x menos a x menos una constante
elevado al cuadrado y esto es igual hay
menos b y bueno es que lo padre de todo
esto es que acabamos de llegar a la
ecuación de una parábola mientras con lo
que empezamos fue pues la propiedad de
que teníamos un punto que tenía
exactamente la misma distancia a otro
punto que se llamaba foco ya una recta
que se llamaba directriz y hasta puedes
jugar con ello podrás decir a ver
cuáles son todos los puntos que cumplen
que la distancia de un punto a otro sea
la mitad o el doble o el triple o lo que
sea a la distancia a una recta llamada
directriz y entonces vas a obtener otras
secciones cónicas recuerdas los conos en
r3
bueno pues cada uno de los cortes de un
cono los puedes obtener jugando con
estas ideas y es que al final descubrir
por ti mismo
cada una de estas ecuaciones que estamos
obteniendo es lo más divertido de las
matemáticas
muchas veces el ver que todo encaja
pieza por pieza en las matemáticas es lo
más divertido de las matemáticas pero
bueno ya hasta aquí hemos llegado aquí
si tenemos un punto que es equidistante
a otro punto llamado foco ya una línea
recta llamada directriz entonces
forzosamente tiene que estar en una
parábola ahora qué pasa si yo me tomo
una parábola me voy a tomar una palabra
en forma general de menos 1 es igual
es que me estoy tomando una parábola
porque ahora vamos a abrir en sentido
contrario y bueno ya no es solamente una
constante ahorita van a ver a qué me
refiero que menos de uno es igual a la
letra a mayúscula que multiplica a su
vez a x menos x 1 elevado al cuadrado no
te asustes con esta x 1 y esta y 1 al
final x 1 y 1 son solamente constantes
son solamente números que están al lado
de la x del ayer y ahora lo que me
quiero preguntar es ya que tengo yo mi
ecuación de mi parábola es decir esta
que está aquí como podemos encontrar
entonces las coordenadas del foco y la
directriz habrá alguna forma de
encontrar dada una ecuación de una
parábola la directriz y el foco y bueno
eso es lo que me voy a preguntar y si
eso es cierto entonces date cuenta que
esta expresión que tengo aquí tiene que
ser igual a este de aquí y tiene que ser
igual a x 1 y de cristianos sabemos x 1
tiene que ser precisamente a que era la
coordenada en x de mi foco y eso es
bastante bueno porque al final
ya sabemos algo de mi foco la coordenada
en x es decir a de mi foco está dada por
x1 que por cierto si lo cual es la
primera vez que hablamos de parábolas
dijimos que el foco estaba ubicado en el
punto x 1 y 1 y bueno de hecho sabes lo
que voy a hacer lo que voy a hacer es ya
no expandir más este tema y mejor
hablarte en el siguiente vídeo de este
tema para que este vídeo no se haga muy
largo